Hello Freak bitches.
What a week young Jim Norton has had
what a week.
Guess what a week.
Sirius satellite radio has had what a
week censorship has had,
what a week Anthony Kumina has had,
what a week.
All the people online that loved the
bitch and Piss and Moan and complain and
get very excited when something fucked
up goes down.
Well,
something fucked up.
Went down when,
if you're listening to this,
if it's sometime in the future because
these recordings will be saved forever.
This is today's date is July 17th.
Two thousand and 14.
Approximately a week ago.
Anthony Kumina was taken photographs.
Anthony of the opiod Anthony Show,
which our pal Jim Norton is also a part
of was he was downtown in New York,
taking some photographs and from there
on it's a bunch of,
you know,
what,
what he says and what I'm sure the woman
who beat the shit out of them would have
a different story,
but he was taking some photographs.
One of one of the photographs was of
this,
uh,
what are those things called when you,
those things we scaffold staffing.
Scaffolding,
who's walking through the scaffolding,
a woman was coming towards him.
It looked like he was just taking a
bunch of cool photos of New York.
There's a bunch of them that he put up
on his instagram.
Anyway,
this woman got upset that he was taking
a photo of her,
probably thought that he was perving,
got mad at them,
violence ensued.
She hit him and he went on twitter and
went on this rant about violence,
about the black community and their
propensity for violence about this woman
calling her an animal,
which she did,
and a serious fire them and which left a
fucking huge hole in my entertainment
world.
The opiod,
anthony shows my all time favorite radio
show.
I listened to it all the time and now
all of a sudden it is no more.
Yeah,
it's a,
you know,
it's a huge hole to no one panicked like
may cause opie and Anthony both have.
Fuck you money.
Jim Norton doesn't so selfishly
thinking,
I'm like,
well,
there goes everything because the show's
done.
You are always going to be great because
you're a funny comment and they can
always work and you never have to worry
about that.
But um,
it is a crazy thing,
uh,
that,
you know,
all of a sudden like that for things
that he said on the show 100 times.
I think when I started,
I think what happened was he tweeted,
like he told,
I talked to him multiple times since
then he was walking and people don't
believe that he was actually taken
legitimate New York photos.
That was one of the points of
contention.
People like he was being creepy,
but he really wasn't like anthony has
had this giant Hubble like camera in the
studio everyday for probably six months
now he's getting into photography.
It's what he's been doing.
So that was not unusual at all to hear.
He was out and about taking photos.
That's legit.
And I guess this woman got angry and I,
I talked to him and he said that she
just said something like,
you know,
this white boys taking my picture,
you wiped by the or whatever.
She said she clocked him and he kept
defending himself as he's putting his
arms.
She is going,
don't touch me like,
you know,
that thing like that a woman might do to
prevent you from hitting her.
Like you could see how frightening that
would be because then people think
you're beating on this woman.
So he's putting his hand up and,
you know,
I know well enough to know he's not
going to just punch a woman in the
phase.
So she's doing that and I think a few
black guys came round and they didn't do
anything to amp,
but there were like,
you know,
don't touch her.
So,
um,
you know,
and who has always armed and he's
licensed to carry,
didn't hit her.
It didn't pull out his pistol and uh,
went home and I guess was really upset
and went out on,
like you said,
a twitter rampage.
And um,
I knew it was bad the next morning when
I saw it because my ex girlfriend called
me and she's like,
what happened with Anthony got beat up
by a woman?
And I don't know.
So I looked and I saw the tweets.
I'm like,
Oh,
I actually texted him about one.
I don't think I've ever done that
before.
There was one that I texted her around
like,
it was you.
All right,
man,
does it?
He's like,
yeah,
I'm fine.
I'm Coco was scary.
Wow.
Um,
yeah.
The,
the thing about Andy is he's developed
this sort of style of communicating on
the show where he goes on these long,
hilarious,
entertaining profanity filled rants and
there's one thing about hearing it,
but there's another thing of like seeing
it in a text form is just not the same.
It looks things don't look good in
print.
Certain things.
And I think what happened was,
is in the middle of like when you have
either contextual conversation,
it's like you have people,
there's inflection,
there's another guy next to you go,
well,
hey,
what do you mean by that?
And then you're clarifying it or it's
just,
it's a different energy when you're
tweeting and you're that mad.
Like I think like any type of an
assault,
even if it's a woman hitting you and
it's not life threatening,
it's still like an hour later you're
like,
what the fuck?
Just happened like I think it just
freaked him out and she hit him a couple
times,
five times or so,
and she sent me a picture of his face
and he had like a little.
You could see that he had been struck,
you mean it wasn't making it up and so
he went on and when I looked at the flow
of things like I know anthony and I know
what he's saying.
He was not calling all black people
animals.
He wasn't because he's never said that
he's talking about a behavior of this
woman and I think that what happened was
he was so mad and when you're tweeting
that aggressively and you've just,
you're fucking dealing with this in your
head that sometimes things come out
jumbled and muddied and like if you know
what he's saying,
people who don't know him or reading
this score,
what does he mean?
He's saying that there's violence in
black people and their animals,
like people are putting these pieces of
a puzzle together and they're making a
picture and it was like,
it just.
I know him well enough to know that in a
conversation.
If someone said,
are you trying to say black people or
animals,
he would go,
no,
not at all.
It's a behavioral based to,
you know what I mean?
Because you said that about white people
too.
So I mean it was just one of those
things where once it was in print,
it's even in context,
we lie as a country like,
you know,
like when cancel cancelcolbert came out
the,
the
activist knew the context that he was
making those Asian jokes and didn't give
a fuck.
She still wanted to sink them.
She's like,
no,
I get it.
He was trying to,
you know,
show the difference between the same
thing between this and native Americans
and how ridiculous it is,
but I don't care.
So we've gotten to a point now where we,
we don't even pretend to not understand
the context anymore.
We admit that we understand the context
of we go after people anyway.
So something like this is bound to a to
sink you because it can be taken both
ways unless you actually sit there and
talk to the guy and each tweet has to
come out like a film.
Each tweet has to be a beginning,
middle and end with no explanation
needed around it in order to to be
survivable.
Right.
Makes Sense.
Well,
you know,
want the big,
big key to what you said that it could
sink you.
Well,
it only syncs you if you work for a
company and in my opinion that's
unnecessary and in this day and age it's
unnecessary.
And I think you guys,
and I think Anthony for sure would be
far better off with a podcast.
Anybody can get a podcast and put it on
their phone.
Now everybody's phone has a little Jack
that sticks into your car and you play
your phone through your car.
Everybody has that now.
I mean,
it's not an uncommon thing.
It's more common to have that Jack than
it is to have satellite radio.
Most people have to get a satellite
radio thing installed in their car.
Most people already have that.
Jack,
you know,
it's just,
it's so God damn easy and I get.
I bet you could get all the same
sponsors.
sponsors and you would have no middleman
and you don't look at the studio.
It's not,
it doesn't take much to put something
together.
You know,
a little bit of time,
little bit of effort.
You know,
you gotta know someone who's an engineer
and knows someone who knows how to put
this stuff together and set up the
microphones.
But other than that,
what's the difference between this and
satellite radio?
I'll tell you what,
the differences.
Nobody can fucking fire you.
You can go on some con rampage,
that fucking animal and no one,
you know,
people might say,
I'm not downloading your podcasts
anymore,
but at least you have the opportunity to
communicate,
to explain yourself.
And if the people decide that they don't
like your character based on one thing
that you said or one rant that you went
on,
that is their decision,
but it's not the decision of a company.
And when things get,
you know,
companies are squirrely,
man,
they have fucking shareholders and
stocks and they have responsibilities
and all you need is a few slash that
start webpages and you know,
fire anthony and Anthony can.
We were going after those sponsors,
we're going to let them know we're
boycotting,
but mostly just noise,
mostly nonsense.
Mostly just soft targets.
But all you need is a few of those in up
a fucking accompany will panic.
They do.
What happens is,
you know,
it's a billion dollar company,
so you get guys like Scott and Jim who
runs it,
who,
you know,
they're just the fourth of July weekend
was coming and then all of a sudden
they're getting phone calls from the New
York Post and the Washington Post and
all the press obviously has a narrative
and they did a shit job.
But the Washington Post I thought was
the worst defender with the way they
covered it because the woman wrote
things that was just
really.
It was revolting to read what she wrote.
She was talking about Anthony saying
that these guys came around and she was
saying like,
oh,
well I guess if a bunch of African
American or how was.
She said,
a bunch of gentlemen want to defend
someone from defaming,
an African American woman.
It's okay.
Like that's what was happening.
She wasn't acknowledging that Anthony
was being hit.
She acted like these guys had read his
twitter feed and not like it.
It was just like she read the twitter
feed in the future.
It was repulsive on this.
A woman who looks like the fucking fake
deaf interpreter from Mandela's funeral
meeting on Anthony.
But uh,
it's a meme,
a meme.
He's rules,
but the company,
these guys just getting,
all of a sudden they're just there.
They're harming.
They're getting phone calls in the
office the day before vacation.
So what are your comments?
And they probably weren't even that
familiar with it until they're getting
calls from the paper and they're like,
well,
what do we do with this?
And then this is what the press does and
this is why you got to hate that.
Because I think Sirius was going to try
to write it out,
that's my opinion,
because they knew a holiday weekend was
coming and uh,
this is purely a guess because no one
was saying anything and then all of a
sudden the press starts going,
we have not had a comment from Sirius
satellite radio.
So we're assuming that they agree with
Mr [inaudible] opinions.
They do this sneaky shit to push you
into defending yourself.
So now the company with shareholders,
like you said,
it has to go,
well,
how do we tell people that we don't
agree with?
So it's not like the presses the made
them do it,
but the press understands how to corner
you into giving a statement,
a definitive statement because they know
that you're not used to this.
They know that these guys come into work
in management positions are not used to
getting phone calls going.
How do you feel about this statement and
that statement,
you know,
it was really,
it was a very frustrating thing when I
saw what the press did with that.
That to me has always been my biggest
complaint is with always will press
this.
There's
no nuance to the way they report on
certain things like this because
there's.
There's nuance to this,
especially if you look into it and
character,
if you in context where either if you
understand that guy and you look at him,
look,
there is a problem with violence in the
black community to pretend there's not a
problem with violence in the black
community is to pretend that there
aren't insane amounts of murders going
on in Chicago to pretend that there's
not issues with the amount of black
people that are in jail.
That percentage of the population now
are those economic problems.
Are those problems related to
upbringing?
Are those pro?
Yes.
Education?
Yes,
absolutely.
There's a lot of fucking disparity.
There's a lot of problems with poverty.
There's a lot of problems with the
structure of our culture itself and that
you could attribute a lot of those
problems to racism,
to racism in the way that funds are
allocated.
The way that you know,
the attention that society puts on
impoverished communities,
absolutely institutionalized,
yes.
But to pretend that it's not a problem
is ridiculous.
It's fucking ridiculous.
So when he's taking a picture of some
chick and she starts punching him,
I think he's allowed to talk about the
problem with violence,
with that community,
with the community that this person is
from.
That's beating him up.
Did he do it the right way?
No,
absolutely not.
Did he do it in a way that could be
misconstrued or construed or interpreted
as racist?
Absolutely did.
Yeah.
He did.
He fucked up.
He did it the wrong way.
He probably shouldn't have done it on
twitter.
He published it and made a video.
It probably should've made a video
explaining,
showing what happened to him and
explaining what goes on.
Explaining this 140 fucking characters
things is a big part of the problem.
Do it.
Absolutely.
That's exactly what it was.
Because Anthony is so good at,
uh,
clarify whatever you talk about race or
a million other things,
whether it's religion,
it,
it's so hard to make your point without
stepping in shit.
And then having to go off on 50 a
digression,
they go,
no,
that's not what I meant,
or no,
that's not what I meant like in.
That's the worst part of the disgusting
stuff is that people jumping on this
side.
What are you saying that all people do?
All black.
No,
I'm not.
So in order to be able to,
to get your point across,
you have to walk a narrow.
You almost have to close people's
argument doors like a get smart episode
as you're walking this way,
your point gets through.
And Anthony is a genius at doing that,
a genius at it because we've debated
race so many times,
uh,
on,
on the show at him and Patrice,
we'd go back and forth and,
and Patrice loved Anthony because he
said Anthony is an adorable racist.
You know,
Patrice was so funny when he never knew,
never was upset by Anthony's opinions
because Anthony would listen to him and
they would go back and forth.
Half The Times Patrice was right and
half the time anthony was right.
But on twitter,
I think like in that emotion when you're
saying x,
Y,
and Z,
he,
I don't think he did as good a job as he
should have done of closing those doors
behind him,
almost like sealing off things that
people can get to you on because he was
so upset because he had had a physical
assault.
And I know it sounds like I'm talking in
circles and just defending my friend,
but I've been with him for 10 years all
in this medium of totally uncensored.
And I'm telling you,
I know him well enough to know that he's
like,
he's got weird things where he'll talk
about race and people misinterpret them
and I've talked to him privately and the
guy does not hate black people and I
know that that's just all his friends
defending him.
But I'm telling you that he does not
because I know him well.
And then to hear people going,
he hates black people.
It's like he's not afraid of being
misconstrued or interpreted as racist.
He's not afraid of it by saying what he
really believes is his opinion about
certain aspects of a group.
Whatever race,
uh,
gender,
whatever it is,
he's not afraid of speaking his mind
about things because he's got them.
Fuck you money.
That's a big part of it.
And he's got 150,000 guns.
Those are the two things.
And you know,
a big part of it that drove me fucking
crazy is people are not,
they're not taking into account the
reaction that someone has when they get
assaulted.
Because when you get hit by someone,
some fucking stranger that you don't
know,
hits you as.
Especially when you've got a garden,
you've got a fucking bullet
gun,
you've got a thing inside you that has
explosions,
you press a trigger,
explosions propel bullets and they end
lives instantly.
And Anthony's an expert with one and he
has it on him at all times and he's
getting hit and he's like,
what the fuck?
And so he gets on my fucking animal con
bitch,
fuck you this back.
You know,
it's getting hit is a very disturbing
thing.
It's,
I mean,
there's one thing to get hit and it's
getting hit in a sparring session is
infuriating with people.
You know,
I've seen people go fucking crazy
because they get choked out in a Jujitsu
session,
getting punched his way more traumatic,
getting punched by a stranger multiple
times for taking a fucking photograph.
I don't know what the exchange was
between the two of them.
I don't know if,
if he was saying something that was
infuriating,
I don't know.
I wasn't there.
You know,
I'm not gonna pretend that was there,
but man,
you've got to take into account the
reaction that people have when you hit
them and it to me,
and again,
I hate to keep going back to the press,
but they didn't focus on the fact that
he like,
he handled himself properly in that
because I know I would have.
I don't know if I would have pulled the
gun in that moment,
but I'm a panicky pete,
that I would have just what other guys
were coming over.
I would have at least brandished it and
he acted physically responsible,
like as a,
as a,
as a fucking guy with a pistol on him
because people get shot all the time for
dumb arguments and dumb things.
He,
he handled himself absolutely right and
lost his cool.
Once he got home and people didn't take
the press,
didn't take that into account.
They harped on the fact that he didn't
get a police report and I wished he had.
Now,
in hindsight,
because they're all going,
Mr Colby did I get a police report,
but here's the deal.
Had he gotten a police report,
they would have just ignored it.
They wouldn't have said,
well,
at least he got a police report.
They would have glanced over the fact
and then said,
yeah,
well I can get a police report.
So they were just using that as a reason
to kind of ignore the fact that he got
hit.
They're like,
we didn't see a police report.
All the press harped on the fact that he
didn't get a police report,
but answer response was,
look man,
you know,
I know enough to know that me getting
hit by some lady in Times Square is not
a fucking priority for NYP ed.
Who's worried about terrorists.
Yeah.
Especially if he's fine.
I think there's a real issue also with
with the press,
with a lot of people in the press,
I'll clarify that.
What they're trying to do is they're
trying to close those getsmart doors as
they write a piece as well and as
they're writing a piece,
they are also trying to placate all the
people that are going to be up in arms
about their opinions.
If they could possibly be supporting a
racist,
if they could possibly be taking your
side,
agreeing with him,
seeing his point of view,
they can be misinterpreted or they could
be interpreted as being racist as well,
so they have to worry about that as
well.
Especially if you're with a liberal rag.
You know,
if you have a very liberal newspaper
that you work for and they have a clear
agenda,
which a lot of them do.
The Washington Times does,
right.
I'll watch the Washington Post rose.
There's a lot of them that have a
liberal slant and if you are reporting
for them,
you know,
and it's something like this that's very
controversial and something where
there's.
There's a bunch of things that
automatically have like a knee jerk
reaction to them and this is one of them
knee jerk reaction to what's conceived
as racist perceived as race.
Yes.
And another thing that they do that's
even,
that's even more enraging is what people
who write for the press now have to do
is not just reporting what happened.
It's how do I editorialize under the
guise of being impartial.
And they do that a lot too and that I
don't like either.
It's like that to me is the worst crime
they commit actually if the
editorializing as they're going along.
Like it's legitimate.
Like uh,
like NBC and I'm on a Zimmerman Fan.
Either aunt was a big supporter.
Zimmerman,
I thought Zimmerman should have went to
jail for something.
I didn't know what legally I have no
ground to stand on,
but I kind of thought he was a con.
But uh,
but,
but not a guy who was out to commit a
murder either.
I thought there was a line in between,
but whatever,
like NBC edited that tape,
like,
ah,
can't do that.
There's no reason to do that unless
you're pushing something,
but they're doing it under the guise of
being impartial and I'm sure they've
done it plenty of times to vilify
blacks.
I'm not saying they have it.
He lost that lawsuit,
you know?
I know he did on.
It's crazy.
It's absolutely nuts.
I don't know why the news has such a
different level of what they can get
away with and what they can do because
they're seen as doing a public service.
In my opinion though,
I think they lost it because everybody
was hating that guy and they just didn't
want him to win something on top of
this.
The fact that he still has his freedom.
The kid lost his life.
Right?
I think he's us.
I think he's a sucky fucking security
guard.
That's what I think.
Yeah.
I think if you're going to look at that
guy and find fault and what he did,
it's how did he handle the situation and
what a more confident,
competent person have handled it the
same way.
Like here's a perfect example.
My friend,
big John Mccarthy who was a cop.
I guarantee you,
you know the referee.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You referenced caught.
That guy was a cop for a long time,
but great guy.
But he knows how to handle shit.
If,
if big John Mccarthy saw that kid
walking in the neighborhood,
he probably would've said,
how you doing man?
Everything cool.
You know,
had a conversation with them.
Everything would've been fine.
Like even if the kid got up in arms or
got mouthy with him,
he would have probably calmed him down,
you know,
without having to get into some physical
altercation.
Not only that,
the kid wouldn't have been able to mount
them and bash his fucking head off the
ground because he's physically
incompetent.
Right?
If you're going to fucking could patrol
a neighborhood,
you can't do it just with a gun.
Can't be.
You can't have the only.
The last resort is your only resort.
You key can't physically defend himself.
He's out of shape.
He's soft and doughy and he's not
physically able to hold that guy off,
but yet he's put himself in this
position where he's like a security.
He's the force of the truth of the law.
You can't do that,
you know you're not.
You're not qualified for that job.
He's just not.
So when that kids on top of them
bouncing his fucking head off the curb,
look,
I don't see any way out for him other
than using a weapon right when that kid
is beating the shit out of him,
but he should have never gotten to that
position.
He shouldn't have.
It should have never escalated to that.
You tell me.
The only way to people can communicate
like that is it comes into violence.
No,
it,
it's how do you deal with it?
How do you communicate?
How did you address this person?
What did you say when he talked back to
you?
What did you say?
What was.
What were the exchange of words?
You know,
when those,
those things.
There's a big difference between.
There's a video that we played the other
day.
What was the.
Do you even lift bro?
You ever see that guy?
The Russian guy?
Is He Russian?
There's even a worse one.
There's practice.
The Pakistani kids though in New York
where the Bronx,
the police chief and Bronx,
New York was like,
stop doing it.
You're going to get killed.
That like these two kids that just go on
youtube and they go up to people in
horrible neighborhoods and are like,
hey man,
you got a problem while he's holding a
calculator and he's just trying to be
funny,
but these guys are just bashing their
heads in and stuff and so the bronx
chief police or something like that
said,
look,
stop it,
but yet these videos more pop.
My point is if you watch those videos,
the guy,
he comes up to people that like look
like your workout and goes,
do you even lift bro?
Look how small you are,
and some people handle it.
Great.
Some people go like,
man,
I don't even don't pull it up.
We don't need to see it.
Some people go,
yeah,
I mean I don't even lift.
You know,
I guess I'm small and then they laugh
and they walk away and some people like
threatened them.
Like it depends entirely on how do
people interact with each other.
And I think that's what we don't know
about the anthony situation.
That's what we don't know about the
Zimmerman situation.
It's not just about what went down,
it's about how did it all play out,
how could it have been avoided?
There's little subtleties in language
like when Jonah Hill is apologizing
recently,
um,
and he's,
he's obviously not a homophobe.
We just got mad and said,
suck my Dick,
faggot.
It was a stupid thing in a moment.
And he's said the tonight show.
And again,
he's just apologizing.
I don't think he never had to deal with
something like this.
And he said something.
He goes back,
the intent doesn't matter,
it's the word,
the words.
And it was like,
again,
I know you're on the spot in that moment
and I'm not going to crucify the guy,
but I wish I was there.
So I could just appear on the seat next
to him.
Like in that woody Allen scene,
when the guy walks out to correct a guy
online and go,
no,
the intent is everything.
Because if the words matter the next
time somebody said the fucking giants
killed the jets,
while we better call the police.
Oh,
that's right.
It's the intent.
We understand every,
every,
every single interaction or phrase has
an intent behind it,
which,
which doesn't always come through in the
written word.
It's just,
it's an inflection.
Something that you and I had a
conversation about with the Tracy Morgan
situation with people pretending that
what he was saying when he was on stage,
you know,
that he was going to stab a sign of
like his whole act is filled with him
saying ridiculous shit.
Yeah.
This is not a statement.
It's not an affidavit.
He's making court.
You're,
you're taking it out of context because
it's the soft target.
If you do that,
yes,
I'm going to stab my son because he's
gay as a statement of fact,
or at the,
at the end of a political rally is a
pretty awful thing to say,
but if you've opened up with I'm going
to get you pregnant and I'm going to
mold shit and make a hat out of it.
It's kind of hard to take any one
statement go,
well that's the serious one,
but that's again,
that's that purposely ignoring context
or even when you can't ignore it,
saying,
yeah,
we understand the context.
We don't fucking care.
It's just soft targets.
People find soft targets and those
targets.
Look if they're all ganging up on
anthony too.
That's the other thing.
I'm not saying Boo Hoo Anthony.
Let's pay attention to what's really
going on.
If you're writing an article out of the
blue for no reason about Jim Norton,
you,
you're the only guy.
I think Jim Norton is a despicable
person and you write this article,
you have the option to respond to that
and you can go,
Whoa,
who are you,
Mr. reporter Dick Wad.
Let's take a look at you,
and then other people can take a look at
him too,
but when everybody's piling on,
it's a free for all.
It's a free ride and then you're there
flailing wildly.
All the Louis Louis ck actually raised a
really good point about that.
When something has happened,
he goes,
you know,
you have to remember to.
Everybody's not googling you like
everyone is not googling Joe Rogan or
Jim Norton or Anthony Cool,
like so you're seeing a every result
about yourself and it appears
overwhelming,
but the reality is like people may be
reading news day or the post or the
Gawker or vice or whatever they're
reading,
but they're not reading every single
article on Anthony Kumiai or on Jim
Norton,
so that's where the overwhelming thing
is sometimes misleading because people
are all reading little snippets of it,
but when the company is getting calls
from again,
five or six different outlets to them it
feels overwhelming and like,
what the fuck do we do with this?
Because this wasn't on the air.
So I think that's where,
and again,
they haven't discussed this with me,
I'm.
I'm purely speculating because to them,
if it was on the air,
I'm guessing they would have said,
well that's what he does on the air.
But they're not looking at it like,
well,
he was reacting to being hit.
I think they just were like,
oh,
okay.
We got a fire.
I think that's why they.
They kind of just reacted very quickly.
I think they fuck themselves.
I really do.
They fuck themselves because they were
supposed to be the place where it was
free speech.
This is the wild place,
but where the fibrous w was the virus
channel member now with Sirius Xm talk.
That's it.
Sirius xm talk.
We have to rename it but we don't know
what would they have?
They have to.
They're not asking for my input.
I don't want my name on the show like I
want.
I want to be on the show,
but I don't,
I don't want to be open.
And Jimmy,
I don't people to feel like I'm jumping
into Anthony's seat because I'm not.
If they call the OPI show a much more
happy with that because that's what it
was before he met Anthony Columbia.
I would call it.
We Miss Anthony.
Uh,
yeah.
That would be kind of a or Tony will
call it Tony so they don't know who
we're talking to.
Bring where's Tony be sneaky.
But it is a horrible.
And it's like people get mad at me and
opiod and say we don't.
And I tried to say like,
we didn't mad at you for what?
Because the,
they,
they people think that we're like a
bunch of teenagers hanging out and like
you guys should walk and support and
it's like,
first of all,
you dumb mother fuckers that say that
Anthony I've talked to,
he wouldn't walk and he told me you got
to make your money like,
and it's all a and B,
I'm under contract.
I can't just walk.
I have three more months in the
contract.
And opie tried to clear this up on the
air.
Like if we just walk out,
if they fire us and we just walk and say
a bunch of more subs leave because they
realize like,
wow,
the show really is gone.
Then all of a sudden serious wants to
take action on us for breach.
It's a whole fucking legal.
People just don't get that part of it.
And they think that we're fucking
anthony.
You know,
who doesn't think we're fucking Anthony
Anthony?
He knows we're not fucking.
Only an idiot thinks you're fucking
anthony,
but there's always going to be idiots
with opinions office.
And I'm fine with that when people say
like,
dude,
I love you and ob,
but I got to cancel because I'm staying
with Anthony.
I don't get mad at those people.
Or if people like I'm going to keep
serious and I'm also going to listen to
ant.
I don't bog.
I'm fine with that too because I get the
emotion,
like whatever they got to do to support
and is cool with me,
I want them to stay because my,
in my ideal world,
they listen to me and opie and then they
fucking listen to Anthony.
There's no competition.
I'm not going to.
We're not like here you don't mention
Anthony.
You don't want to fucking show comes
out.
I'm going to,
I'm going to tweet it because I want him
to succeed because he's one of my
closest friends.
It's gonna succeed.
It's going to.
If you,
you know,
just.
He's an entertaining guy.
He's an interesting guy in the platform
of the Internet is so free and easy and
he's already got a full professional
setup at his house.
Yeah.
People don't know if you've never seen.
One of the main reasons I started this
podcast is because of live from the
compound,
because he said a fucking greenscreen in
his house,
a professional studio,
and he was playing images behind him of
like the city of La.
He had a green screen,
I mean a beautiful green screen like
professional broadcast quality cameras,
like the whole deal.
I was like,
that's amazing and that slowly but
surely led to what you're seeing right
here.
Like him doing that while he was already
on Sirius and Sirius tried to stop them
from doing that.
They got it.
They gave him a hard time about that.
Yeah.
That was it.
I think that was a contractual issue too
where they're like,
look,
this is the medium you're on.
But eventually they're like,
they're of like,
let them do it and they're like,
what do you think is going to go down
September when your contract is up
October fourth?
I don't know.
I mean like I love the Gig,
I love performing,
but you love the Gig.
The same with Anthony not being there.
Of course not.
No,
no.
I mean,
I mean the idea of performing either
alone or with other people.
I want this thing to work because I want
my own thing.
Like I've done so many things being the
vice thing,
Jim Norton show,
I want to have my own thing too,
because you feel like a more complete
performer when you're not always with
Opie and Anthony or Colin Quinn or Louis
Ck or Amy Schumer's put me on her show.
Like I don't always want to be on
somebody else's thing.
Right.
Um,
so I love the idea of performing on the
radio.
I love doing it with Opi.
I love doing it with opie and anthony
more because now let's say the same
thing of opiod left.
Like I honestly do love being a part of
that radio show.
Being without anthony is difficult and
it will be with say the same thing.
It's just like,
it's hard to realize how much space a
person fills in your life until they're
not there.
Like,
I mean,
we all know Anthony's a comic gene.
That's easy to say,
but it's like the little moments,
like when there's that chair,
I mean I'm,
I'm close.
I said closer to um,
to anthony that I do to you everyday,
five days a week for 10 years and that
was just gone and it's really hard to
get used to that empty seat whether he's
saying something funny or whether he's
just doing a stupid Iraq joke or a
little aside or just pipe.
It's like this whole fucking vacuum of
this,
this great powerful brain that used to
be,
you know,
a foot away from it.
Yeah.
Or just talking about things.
He's a fascinating guy.
He's got a lot of information in his
head.
He can talk about anything for any
length of time,
anything he could be.
And we've said that,
like I've said this before,
Patrice said that anthony can access
funny faster than anybody he'd ever
known.
Like he just had the ability to access
being funny immediately on any subject.
Like if you talking like,
you know,
he was a tin knocker.
He had put in air conditioning vents and
he can walk you through that in a
fascinating way.
And be funny about it and be captivating
with it.
Me,
I just die telling a story.
I lose people in me.
It's a joke I've done,
but I meant the sincerity of it that if
I was on nine slash 11 on the,
if I made it out of the first tower,
I would lose people halfway through the
story.
Like I just have no ability to go from
the beginning to the middle to the end
and keep people locked in.
Did you guys have a meeting with serious
after this?
No.
No,
opiates.
We talked to Scott.
I talked to Scott on the phone and he
goes,
look,
we're going to try to move forward with
you and open and see how it happens.
He goes,
worked through it organically on the
air.
They didn't tell us how to do it.
They didn't say don't bad mouth the
company don't.
He said worked through it organically on
the air and what we'll see what happens.
So I mean see what happens if they
completely closed the idea of anthony
ever coming back.
I don't think so.
Um,
and,
and they've given me no indication.
So I'm careful how I say that because I
don't want the fans getting like I'm
putting false hope out there,
but I'm just being truthful is it
doesn't feel final to me and maybe
that's my own denial or my own lack of
willingness to admit that this thing
could be over.
Like it was really sad,
man.
I last I saw,
I don't think I went to his fucking
fourth of July party and I was very
depressed driving home.
Like I know I'm going to be okay
financially and I know like,
Hey,
there's other show could take off.
you got stand up.
Hey you got.
But just the idea that this thing you
love to do,
like this chapter is closed.
Like just fucking depresses me.
Depresses me to listen to it.
I can imagine if it was me every day,
day in day out being a part of it.
Every time I did it,
I loved it.
I mean I had a great time doing your
show.
So my favorite radio show of all time,
without a doubt.
It's a real conversation.
You have real moments and the laugh
somebody played for me recently are,
they sent me a link to Jim Norton's
laugh compilation.
There's just times where people have
made me laugh on the show and I listened
to part one and two because the point is
not me laughing.
It's the things.
And in most of those laughs I've come
from anthony more than any gas or
anybody and some of the things that he
did a thing recently or years ago that I
heard two days ago where we were talking
about people who have shot themselves in
the head and survived.
And Anthony did the voice of the guy who
survived and he just wanted an
immediate.
He became the guy who had shot himself
in the fucking head in survivors talking
about how he just has a more positive
outlook and I'm howling listening to it
in the clip and I'm listening to it.
Uh,
uh,
like,
you know,
two days ago.
And I'm laughing all over again.
I'm like,
I forgot that bit ever existed,
but God is cocksucker made me fucking
laugh.
And I'm not talking about him like he's
dead.
But I mean that's how valuable a thing
he is.
Like I said,
I can't listen to two radio.
They made a big mistake.
I think they made a bigger stake for
them for a
couple reasons.
One,
I think they made a big mistake because
I think it's going to open the door more
to the Internet because people are going
to look at that as the only last
remaining true free speech option
because that's what it is.
Look,
you can.
You could say you don't like this
podcast.
You can decide that I'm offensive.
You can do it,
but you can't stop it.
I mean you might,
even though the host might say,
we don't want to host you anymore,
I'll find another host.
Those sponsors might say,
we don't want to be your sponsor
anymore.
Well guess what I'll do with no sponsor.
We did it with no sponsors for years.
This is the only real option where
you're your own producer,
your own director,
your own.
You're the whole thing.
You're the performer.
That's where it's sad because just like
a standup is entirely responsible for
your act.
You put on stage,
if you had some producer hovering over
your fucking shoulder every time you
wrote a bit,
every time you were thinking about
putting together a set list,
every time you are going up and doing a
show,
they would review it afterwards.
That would be gross.
That would take all the fun out of being
a comic.
Yeah,
it would be awful.
I mean that's why I'm a bad collaborator
because you're so used to having
absolute and ultimate control of things.
So you're a perfect example.
Think about you and you as a successful
performer and personality.
Who the fuck would have ever thought you
could have made a mainstream career out
of talking about your love of trannies,
talking about shit and Piss and shit and
in each other's mouths and peeing on
people.
Monster rain.
Just look at the honest things that
you've tackled because you're honest
because you're funny.
If you had to vet that through somebody
else,
if you had to have that filter through
some sort of a mainstream producer,
it would've never happened.
Never work.
You're absolutely right.
I mean,
that's why you're right though.
The Internet is the last place where at
least for now,
who the fuck knows what happens with
that,
but all that stuff you did,
you did on serious,
serious at a different approach.
When they first came out,
they.
They've slowly but surely clamped down
from that Condoleeza Rice incident.
That's where it was like,
Ooh,
you could get in trouble for something
that someone says on a radio show that
isn't even like
a guest.
I mean,
isn't even one of the hosts,
right?
He was at your show could get canceled,
a homeless guy and they were going to
fire us.
That Eric Logan sailor that was accent.
It wasn't sure it was,
and this is how.
What happened?
The fucking the NAB National Association
of broadcasters.
Somebody on that side I think was what
was pushing it.
Could the story went on?
Drudge and Breitbart,
will this hurt the merger?
And again,
the guys who ran the this,
when they're about to merge,
will this injure the merger?
And Man,
it was a billion dollars at stake and
then it wasn't going to hurt the merger,
but they fucking panicked.
And these are all different people that
are in charge now.
Uh,
but they're like,
well,
uh,
and they don't know how to deal with
stuff.
So they get the phone call.
The Guy Nate I think was running at the
tower cupid's Arrow.
What do you think of this thing?
They said a homeless guy said he wants
to rape Condoleezza Rice.
And like he,
he's worried about a billion dollar
merger and I'm not defending them
suspending us.
But I try to put myself in there like,
and this is a guy I mentioned,
Louis because he's a good,
he's a good nonemotional reactor to
things and he'll look at things and go,
well they're just trying to do this.
And like Louis will give you a very
logical reason as to why something's
happening.
And it's like,
yeah,
I wish I would've seen that.
I get too angry and emotional and you're
like,
fuck that.
And they're say.
And then I'll go like,
okay,
that's a billion dollar company.
They're not used to this.
And they hear this guy wants to fucking
first lady raped Bush or George Bush and
they're laughing about merger.
Might be threatened to fuck,
get rid of him.
And he just panics.
Isn't it fascinating though that you're
talking about a billion dollar company?
Okay.
Sirius xm billion dollar company.
What exactly are they selling?
What they're selling is content.
Who delivers that content?
Guys like opie and Anthony,
guys like Jim Norton.
They're selling your ability to be
entertaining.
Other than that,
it's just music.
How you,
how do you have a billion dollar company
that's just selling music?
Well,
I don't.
That's where my argument would be to.
It looked the talk thing is the last,
like the last thing you guys have,
and this is for any evil terrestrial
radio to the last thing.
You have his original talk content and
their point back would be,
well that's a great thing that we have,
but we also have,
um,
whether it's a celebrity,
people doing shit or we have sports that
you can't get across.
Let's say we have the MBA,
we have a major league baseball game.
I'm just saying that's what they would
say.
Yeah,
but nobody's paying for that.
Let's be honest.
They're paying for stern.
They're paying for Opie and Anthony.
I hope so,
man.
Especially since spotify and Pandora,
they used to be.
I like Sirius Radio because they had the
thirties to forties to fifties,
whatever and all the different radio
stations.
Nowadays you just put spotify put
anything you want and as you know.
Yeah,
I mean I.
I get almost all my shit from itunes.
I don't ever listen to music in my car
anymore unless it's coming off with my
phone.
I just just,
I don't need to.
You don't need to anymore.
You don't need them anymore.
And the last thing that's exciting is
things like stern and things like
opie and anthony where you can have a
guy who is just freewheeling,
same whatever he wants,
doesn't have to worry about language
restrictions.
Does it have to worry about anything?
And the fact that he can get fired for
saying the same things that he's always
said on his show to saying them in a
text message that they're so ignorant
that they can't recognize that this is.
You're taking it out of context.
You're taking it from a guy who just
recently been assaulted.
You're taking it from a guy,
probably had a couple of drinks in him
when he said it and he shouldn't have
done it.
He fucked up.
He definitely shouldn't have gone on
that twitter rampage.
He should have said it on a video
and you know what podcast or on the show
up on the shelf on the show.
It would have been perfect.
It would've been a great episode.
Oh,
that would been fun.
And,
and Keith Robinson pointed out,
he's like the teasing.
We could've given him a that teasing
beautiful but it.
But I don't know if that's something
that will ever change.
Like they may at one point,
we do kind of understand that maybe
he's,
you know,
he's a valuable asset to the like,
again,
I don't,
I don't know why I don't get that
feeling because they haven't said to me
we'll bring him back.
They really haven't and I never want to
give fans.
I'm not trying to keep fans from who it
literally is just a feeling,
a gut feeling.
He didn't drop any bombs.
He didn't go on this and I've talked to
him enough to know what his intent was
and maybe I'm just naive dummy in me,
but I keep thinking,
man,
he should come back,
he can come back.
Just give it some time and I just keep
hoping for that.
I think he
can come back.
I think if they gave it some time,
he definitely can come back in the
context of what he said wasn't that bad.
You know?
I wouldn't have been happy if it was my
company and I had shareholders and all
that jazz,
but I obviously I would never be that
guy anyway.
I would never be a fucking head of a big
company.
I'm just not built for it,
but you got to recognize the
entertainment quality,
you know the entertainment aspect of
that guy,
the entertainment possibilities of
keeping the show together.
It's his.
Without that all,
you have a stern,
you know,
obviously you guys are still together
and they'll still be a great show,
but it's not the same show and you leave
open the door for anthony starting his
own thing,
some wildly successful thing on the
Internet,
which also look,
if someone comes along and they put
together some sort of an advertising
budget and they say,
hey listen,
we would like to do the top.
We'd like to host the opiod.
Anthony podcasts on the Internet will
take x percentage of the.
The advertisers.
We've already got it lined up.
We have a big launch.
We're going to do it around
thanksgiving.
Someone's going to fuck a Turkey.
Live on the air,
you know,
whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
You start,
you start doing.
You come up with some idea to do
something completely free and wild on
the Internet.
A big advertising push,
buy billboards,
Time Square,
you know,
fuck serious.
We're doing it on the Internet,
you know ONA is back and it's free.
Downloaded online.
You don't need to pay for a subscription
anymore.
Anybody can get it on your phone.
I mean you could do it.
The way we do it,
we're,
we're available on were were available
online as an MP.
Three were available from itunes.
We're available on Stitcher,
on Youtube,
on Ustream,
on Vimeo.
If you just did something like that,
it would be.
Yeah,
maybe you're right,
man.
Who we have thought about it and again,
we're up in October fourth,
we don't know.
We honestly don't know what we do from
here.
Like again,
opiod,
I are doing the shell,
bringing guests in and just performing
and it's like we both feel the fucking
last go through.
Vice do it all through vice.
There'll be a wonderful promotion
vehicle to for guys to do.
Opie and Anthony Live through vice.
They'll set you up with a studio.
Do it all online,
do the show as a video online and
through the show.
Have it available as a podcast.
Free downloads.
They provide you with advertisers.
Wouldn't be hard to do.
Shane could hook that up in five
seconds.
They can make one phone call and it
would be.
The wheels would be in motion.
I would,
uh,
I would love to do that.
And that's a guy that you,
you know,
like she could get really crazy and
everyone's going to be fine.